>> Laura: COULD HISTORY BE
REPEATING ITSELF WITH
OVERZEALOUS PROSECUTOR SEEKING
FAME AND GLORY?
MARK VARGAS CITED THE FATE OF
FORMER ILLINOIS GOVERNOR, ROB
BLAGOJEVICH OF ILLINOIS.
DEMOCRAT IS SERVING A 14 YEAR
SENTENCE FOR CORRUPTION.
VARGAS ARGUED THAT THE STOMACH
HE WAS A VICTIM OF OVERZEALOUS
PROSECUTION.
IT WAS THEN THAT FBI DIRECTOR
BOB MUELLER, WHO IN 2008
AUTHORIZED A TOTALLY UNNECESSARY
AND RUTHLESS PREDAWN RAID OF THE
GOVERNOR.
HERE WITH US EXCLUSIVELY ARE
BLAGOJEVICH'S WIFE, PATTY, AND
CHICAGO ATTORNEY LYNN GOODMAN,
WHO REPRESENTS THE FORMER
GOVERNOR.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
PATTY, YOUR HUSBAND HAS BEEN IN
JAIL FOR NOW SEVEN YEARS OF A 14
YEAR SENTENCE.
HE WAS CONVICTED ON A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT CORRUPTION CHARGES,
BRIBERY AND EXTORTION I BELIEVE.
I THINK WHEN PEOPLE HEAR THAT
THEY THINK, HE MUST HAVE TAKEN A
BRIBERY, OR PROMISE TO DO
SOMETHING FOR SOMEONE GIVING HIM
MONEY, AND HE MUST HAVE BEEN
HEARD OR THERE MUST HAVE BEEN
DOCUMENTARY EVIDENCE SAYING ALL
THAT.
BUT IN FACT, NONE OF THAT
HAPPENED.
>> NONE OF THAT AT ALL.
FOR ME LISTENING TO YOUR SHOW,
IT'S ALMOST LIKE YOGI BERRA
SAYS, DEJA VU ALL OVER AGAIN.
TEN YEARS AGO, THE SAME PEOPLE,
COMEY, FITZGERALD AND MUELLER,
THESE OUT-OF-CONTROL PROSECUTORS
CAME AFTER MY HUSBAND WITH THEIR
UNCHECKED POWER TO UNDO AN
ELECTION BY THE PEOPLE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE SO FAR FROM
ELIOT NESS, THEY ARE A MILLION
LIGHT
LIGHT YEARS AWAY.
THEY ARE USING THEIR OFFICES FOR
THEIR OWN PERSONAL ENRICHMENT TO
FURTHER THEIR CAREER TO SELL
BOOKS.
SPEED >> Laura: I DON'T THIK
SPEED >> Laura: I DON'T THIB
MULLER NEEDS TO FURTHER HIS
CAREER, HE IS THE FBI DIRECTOR.
HE'S ESTEEMED BY REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS.
HOWEVER, AND YOU COULD GET IN ON
THIS, HE DID AUTHORIZE A RAID
THAT WAS REMINISCENT OF MANNA PU
THAT WAS REMINISCENT OF MANNA PL
MANNA FORT AND COHEN.
IT WAS A PREDAWN RAID, THEY GO
IN AND TAKE EVERYTHING OUT OF
THE APARTMENT.
AND IT HAPPENED TO YOU GUYS.
>> IT COMPLETELY UNNECESSARY AND
A WHITE COLOR CASE.
THEY COULD HAVE CALLED THE
LAWYER AND HE WOULD HAVE COME
DOWN AND SURRENDERED.
TO DO THAT TO HIS TWO YOUNG
CHILDREN WAS DISGRACEFUL.
>> WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT
PATRICK FITZGERALD, FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE WATCHING ARE LIKE, WHY
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THIS GUY,
PATRICK FITZGERALD?
IT GOES BACK INTO THE 80s, AND
HE WENT BACK TO SCOOTER LIBBY.
OUTRAGEOUS PROSECUTION, AND HE
WENT AFTER CONRAD BLACK.
THE COURT PART OF THAT
CONVICTION OVERTURNED BY THE
SUPREME COURT.
AND OF COURSE NOT ONCE BUT TWO
TIMES, THEY TRIED BLAGOJEVICH.
THE COURT SADLY DIDN'T TAKE THE
CASE A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO AND
THEY COULD HAVE CLEARED UP THIS
RIDICULOUS FEDERAL BRIBERY
STATUTE WHICH IS EXTREMELY
CONFUSING, WIDE ENOUGH TO DRIVE
A TRUCK THROUGH.
AND YET HE IS PRAISED FOR
BEING -- IS THE MOST ESTEEMED
PERSON.
HE DID THE ENRON INVESTIGATION
AND THE ENRON CASE.
BUT THERE WERE PROBLEMS THERE,
TOO.
ARTHUR ANDERSON ENDS UP GETTING
EXONERATION
EXONERATED, MEANWHILE THEY LAID
OFF 85,000 PEOPLE IN THE INTERIM
OFF 85,000 PEOPLE IN THE INTERI
INTERIM.
IN SOME CASES, THEY ARE
PROTECTING THEM BUT THEY HAVE
UNCHECKED POWER OFTEN TIMES AND
IT CAN BE OUT OF CONTROL.
AND I'M SORRY, BUT AS I SPEAK OF
THE FORMER CRIMINAL DEFENSE
ATTORNEY, I DON'T WANT TO BE ON